[Music]
yes good morning today we're about to
talk about the subject is very close to
my heart as a practicing doctor and
psychiatrist an ever-growing number of
people are being treated for mental
illness we know that for a fact a lot of
us play met on the modern world but
critics warned that psychiatrists ought
to be in cahoots with big pharma I've
got an interest in describing normal
perhaps even fundamental aspects of
human behavior as an illness or a
condition or a disorder have to be
better to give up that whole idea try it
out altogether what we're doing that can
sign the very very sick to a lack of
misery I think it's fair to say we had
three of the country's top experts on
the very subject on my right he's
professor Richard Bentall sure of his
books which you could say against the
argument circuitry are really quite
thought changing you've made a serious
contribution to the cycling debate on my
far left is Lucy Johnston Lucy for many
years has been working on alternative
frameworks that look far more
importantly at the psychological and
social and the power balances that go on
between people when they become mentally
disordered our third speaker today is
the the only MBBS wielding doctor on the
panel and John and you were a GP for
seven or eight years working in the
frontline clinical practice but you
became quite interested in the obvious
nosov psychological and social factors
in illness so let's let battle commence
is the modern world making us ill or are
we medicalizing normality Richard we
start with you from the moment you wake
up in the morning to the point when you
go to sleep at night and possibly beyond
because sleep affects your mental health
you are swimming in the causes of mental
health and ill health it says your
relationships with the people the social
and economic environment you live in and
so on and these are very powerful
determinants of mental health we
shouldn't think of mental health as over
having a mental illness or not
we should think of continuer between
mental health and mental illness and
those social factors knock you along or
back and forth longer continues so where
we drove a line between health and
illness is to some extent arbitrary
although we shouldn't Duchin worriers
all that much because that's true a lot
of physical illnesses like hypertension
as well
what we should be wary of is seeing
these phenomenon is largely medical
phenomena which require medical
intervention rather than responses to a
world which is challenging and difficult
to live in and difficult to navigate our
way through and we should think about
how we can change the world in order to
make it that we are lower down that
continuum more towards the side of
healthy functioning and able to live our
lives in a fulfilling way thank you Lucy
okay I think the problem is that this is
going to be less of a battle than a
loving as earlier because actually we
come from all the similar positions but
I mean just to expand a bit on what
Richards are said which I do agree with
there's quite a lot of evidence that
something about modern Western
industrialized societies is making us
more and I wouldn't use word mental
illness is making us more miserable and
unhappy in a way that expressing itself
in all sorts of different ways and of
course people have always been mad or
distressed but you know we haven't
always had this rising epidemic of what
I would not call mental illness and part
of this I think along with a genuine
increase in distress is also a process
of us be encouraged to medicalize things
that certainly would be seen as normal
aspects of everyday life
you know 10 20 30 years ago we could all
think of examples of that but
essentially I think we're living in an
increasing individualistic and
materialistic and competitive and
fragmented society and that is not good
for all of us for any of us it's not
healthy for any of us where I would
differ a bit from Richard is I'm very
picky about language I would not call
this mental illness we're not dealing
with people patients with illnesses but
people with problems people are at some
level are responding in an
understandable way to a huge range of
social pressures and relationship
difficulties and social norms and
expectations which have really become
almost crippling for many of us and
actually despite all the well-meaning
anti steeper campaigns and so on and
there's something to support there we
are not going to tackle this so-called
epidemic of so-called mental illness
until we really make an effort to live
in a just a fairer more equal society
and what's your take
so the world I work in is bringing
together
the biological reasons the social
reasons and the psychological reasons so
I think on that front even though I'm
medical we're very much on a similar
page but I guess it's about why do we
feel like there might be an epidemic
they do big surveys and these big
surveys fight can can say who has an
actual diagnosis who meets the threshold
for anxiety and depression there has
been a slight increase in anxiety in
depression but it's not huge and it's
mainly in older adolescent girls but
what has changed dramatically if the
people is about people knowing that
their arm well so it used to be that you
might meet the criteria for anxiety and
depression but you wouldn't know it so
if someone said are you depressed
you'd go No and you wouldn't seek help
what's happening now is that people are
much more aware when they might be
hitting those thresholds and and when
they hit those thresholds they're more
likely to seek out still the people who
hit those thresholds there's only less
than half of people with diagnosable
common mental disorders are for help but
our mental health systems are
chronically underfunded and have been
for years and we can't meet that growing
awareness and I think that gives people
a sense of an epidemic the modern life
has changed so the areas that I do
research in particularly our young
people's mental health and suicide and
self-harm prevention and so I always get
asked about social media about
individuals about how rapidly our world
is changing change brings discomfort
brings sometimes a sense of moral panic
I noticed that n used the terms
threshold for anxiety and depression as
though they were things though he warned
about the dangers of language but what
I'd like to do then is come down to
another word biological is all illness
biological mental illness or physical
illness come to that
I think both physical and mental illness
are hugely impacted by people's social
circumstances so I come from the public
health background I think poverty plays
a huge impact certainly people you have
who who would think of themselves or
services might think of them as having
mental illness they definitely
experience what we might term biological
symptoms they feel unwell however to
change people's social circumstances
often requires political will I think
that's why sometimes we focus very much
on on the medical model because that's
something that people can do something
about where some of these broader social
aspects much more complicated to impact
you may have biological predispositions
but social causation I come from public
health and primary care I think you know
substance misuse poverty those are the
things that have a real impact on
people's mental health Richard what
you'll take on that so to answer the
question yes it's biological because
everything is biological every time you
think something happens in your brain
and one of the things which has changed
in my career is our ability to to see
those things because we have
neuroimaging techniques if you look at
the brains of people who have diagnosed
with psychiatric disorder its definitive
the brains are functioning in a
different way there's no question about
that it's complicated because there's
different ways for different types of
problems and so on the problem is how we
think about that the temptation has
always been to say well you know we've
got something funny going on the brain
scanner that means it's a biological
illness it doesn't mean anything of a
sort what we also know is that life
experience changes the way the brain
functions I think without a shadow of
doubt that childhood abuse is causal
it's a big word cause but I'm prepared
to use it in this circumstances is
causal in adult psychiatric disorders
and it plays a role in the type of most
severe disorders which I'm interested in
which would call the psychosis I'm
there's any question about that we also
know from brain scanning studies
that children who are sexually abused
that their brains develop in subtly
different ways so for example the
hippocampus which is an ear region in
the center of the brain tends to be
small and what's going on is the brain
is responding to events in the world and
so where do we say is the cause of the
mental illness I'd say it's the events
in the world and the brain is a kind of
what we'd say as a mediator it's just
kind of what's what's bar the part you
want say something you so I think the
only difficulty I have with that so I
think what you're saying is completely
right so that's sort of childhood trauma
whether it's abuse or neglect has a huge
impact but but the one thing that we do
know is that one risk factor plus
another does not equal illness okay so
it's so so I think that's where I move
slightly away from causal right so so
here you are saying but then we need a
different understanding of what we mean
by calls in what I wouldn't call mental
illness because you help us yes okay
because obviously it's not the case that
tragically this person was sexually
abused they're going to end up with
something that we might call
schizophrenia or twenty years down the
line for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at III TV
you